hey this is pressure Locker an evil
warden holds you prisoner but offers you
a chance to earn your freedom you are
given a hundred and one coins of which
51 are genuine and 50 are counterfeit
each counterfeit coin is identical to a
genuine coin except that it differs in
weight by exactly one gram all of the
counterfeit coins are lighter or all of
them are heavier only the warden knows
this information the warden gives you a
randomly selected coin from the hundred
and one coins you have to guess whether
it is genuine or counterfeit if you are
incorrect you are imprisoned forever but
if you are correct then you are set free
you are given a tool to help you are
given a weighing balance that displays
the difference in weight between its
left and right pans for example if the
left pan has 8.3 grams and the right pan
has 10.3 grams the display would show
negative two grams you can weight any of
the hundred and one coins but you only
get to use the weighing balance once
before you have to guess what is your
best strategy to identify your coin and
escape the prison can you figure it out
give this prom a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution it seems impossible because
you're at a huge disadvantage you don't
know the weight of a genuine coin and
you don't know if the counterfeit coin
is lighter or heavier plus the weighing
balance only gives the difference in
weight between its left and right pans
but amazingly you can always escape and
remarkably you don't actually weigh the
coin you need to identify you end up
weighing all of the other coins
here's how it works you place your coin
aside then you split the remaining
hundred coins into left and right pans
with 50 coins in each pan now the
display on the balance will always be an
integer I'll explain why later in the
video if the integer is even that you
initially received a genuine coin if the
integer is odd then you initially
received a counterfeit coin by a clever
mathematical scheme you can outsmart the
evil warden and guarantee your freedom
this will always let you identify
whether your coin is genuine or
counterfeit but why does it work let's
go through a proof
let W equal the weight of a genuine coin
and let C sub I equals the weight of
coin I will number the coins in the left
pan from 1 to 50 and will number the
coins in the right pan from 51 to 100 we
can then write the difference of the
weight in the coins on the left hand pan
from the right hand pan as equaling the
sum of the coins in the left pan minus
the sum of the coins in the right pan we
now are going to introduce the weight of
a genuine coin we'll start out with the
simple expression that 0 is equal to
negative 50 W minus negative 50 W we
will then expand out each term so that
we have 0 equaling negative W 50 times
minus negative W 50 times we can now add
up these equations the reason we're
doing this is we're going to pair the
weight of each coin with the weight of a
genuine coin so we have a result that
left minus right is equal to the sum of
the weight of each coin minus the weight
of a genuine coin we have 100 of these
terms consisting of 50 terms that are
added on the left pan and 50 terms which
are subtracted from the right pan now we
know something about each of these terms
for a genuine coin it's weight is
exactly equal to the weight of a genuine
coin so each of these terms will equal 0
and they'll vanish if all of the
counterfeit coins are heavier than the
weight of a counterfeit coin minus the
weight of a genuine coin will equal 1 if
instead all of the counterfeits are
lighter than the weight of a counterfeit
coin minus the weight of a genuine coin
will equal minus one will consider each
of the
cases separately so let's continue the
proof by considering if all of the
counterfeit coins are heavier so how
many counterfeit coins are there we will
either be weighing 50 counterfeit coins
if we received a genuine coin or we will
be weighing 49 counterfeit coins if we
received a counterfeit so we'll consider
each of these cases suppose that we are
weighing 50 counterfeit coins and
replacing X of them on the left pan and
50 minus X on the right pan
each of these counterfeit coins will
contribute one to this left - right so
we have left - right equals x from the
left pan minus 50 minus X from the right
pan this simplifies to be 2x minus 50
and what's important is that 2x is even
50 is even and the difference of two
even terms is even if instead there were
49 counterfeit coins suppose we placed X
on the left pan and 49 minus X on the
right pan we can again calculate that
left minus right will equal X minus 49
minus X and this simplifies to be 2x
minus 49 the only difference here is
that 49 is an odd number we have an even
number 2 X minus an odd number which
will therefore give us an odd result so
what we figured out is that the evenness
and oddness of our result will depend on
whether we're weighing 50 or 49 coins
that are counterfeit this will also be
true if the counterfeits are all lighter
it's a very similar calculation if we
ended up weighing 50 counterfeit coins
we'll end up with an even result and if
we were weighing 49
counterfeit coins we would end up with
an odd result so we could generalize all
of these cases together whether we're
dealing with heavier or lighter
counterfeit coins if we end up with the
balance showing an even integer that
that means we would have weighed all of
50 of the counterfeit coins so that
means initially we would have received
one of the genuine coins if instead the
balance is showing an odd number that
means we would have been weighing 49 of
the counterfeit coins so initially we
would have received one of those
counterfeit coins therefore with
certainty we can figure out from what
the weighing balance is showing whether
the coin we had is genuine or
counterfeit did you figure this out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel I make videos on
math and game theory you can catch
around my blog mind your decisions which
you can follow on Facebook Google+ and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at pressure Locker and if you liked this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description